Microbes are everywhere on your phone,
in your water bottle,
on your hands before you wash them on your hands after you wash them and
literally everywhere else on top of you to microbes are omnipresent at any
moment and there is nothing we can do about it.
So millions of years ago we made a pact.
We give them shelter and food and in turn they work for us.
But the more we learn about this partnership,
the more it looks like a cold wall
inside our mother's womb.
Humans start out stero when we're born and traveling through the birth canal,
billions of our mother's bacteria cover every single part of our bodies.
This is an essential part of human health.
Children born via c section have a higher rate of asthma,
immune diseases,
and even leukemia.
So our bodies do not only accept the invasion of microorganisms,
they welcome it.
Over millions of years,
we could evolved to make the best of our relationship.
Mother's milk,
for example,
contains a special sugars that are meant to feed and support certain groups of
microbes,
work as a decoy for others and help to modulate the immune system.
It takes up to two years until a healthy microbe community has fault.
Every human has their own unique microbiome made up of bacteria,
viruses,
fungi and other organisms.
We have three categories of guests on and in our bodies.
One quiet passengers that do their own thing and our politely ignored by being
there.
They take up space and keep more aggressive.
Intruders in check two guests that harmless but with whom we've learned to live.
For example,
bacteria that literally create acid that melts our teeth.
If we don't brush enough,
they want to take up as much space as they can and we don't want them to,
but we can't get rid of them entirely.
Three friendly fellows that our bodies want to have around.
Most of them are a community of 380,000 billion bacteria from up to 5,000
different species that live in our gut.
These gut micro organisms help us digest food and pull additional calories from
things we can't digest ourselves.
Unfortunately,
our gut is also the perfect point of attack for intruders,
so it's guided by an aggressive army,
our immune system to survive hair.
Our micro biome coevolve with us to be able to communicate with our body.
The most important part of that is to ask the immune system to not kill them,
but they also have a real motivation to keep our gut healthy.
So some of them produce messenger substances that help to educate the immune
system and others stimulate the gut cells to regenerate faster.
But over the last few years,
evidence has emerged that the influence of our gut micro biome goes much,
much further.
It might even talk directly to our brain.
We've observed a few curious things.
90% of our body's Serotonin and important messenger substance for nerve cells is
produced in the gut.
Some scientists think the microbiome does this to communicate with the Vegas
nerve,
the information highway of our nervous system.
Other examples are bacteria.
That's to me innate immune cells in the gut.
So they send the kind of alarm signal to the brain here.
It activates immune cells that help the brain recover from injuries.
Since the brain decides where we eat,
the micro biome is interested in a healthy brain.
A new field of science is opening up here and we're just on the verge of
understanding how these complex systems inside our bodies interact.
But we are starting to see how much our microbiome actually influences us and
our behavior.
Take depression,
for example,
healthy rats fed microbes from the guts of depressed people began showing
anxiety like behavior and symptoms that look like depression.
And in early 2017 a study link the micro biome to intelligence by connecting a
certain setup of bacteria in newborns with better motor and language skills,
but it might also influence our daily lives tests with fruit flies so that their
microbiome influenced what kinds of food they craved.
This could mean your microbes are able to tell your brain which food it should
get them.
Although this is not a one way street,
the seed for our microbiome comes from our mother,
but how it develops and changes is determined by what we eat.
The organisms in our gut feed on different things.
Some like fibers and leafy greens,
others go for sugars and starches and some love greasy fries and butter.
Our gas is like a garden in which we constantly decide what will grow and
blossom.
If we eat healthily,
we breed bacteria that like healthy food.
If we eat a lot of fast food,
then we breed fast food.
Loving bacteria.
Life is hard so we can get trapped in a vicious circle.
You have a stressful time and eat lots of burgers and fries and pizza.
This is awesome for fast food bacteria.
They multiply and multiply and take up space from vegetable loving bacteria but
even worse they send signals to the brain to continue what it's doing.
This makes you want more fast food which breeds more fast food bacteria which
makes you crave fast food and so on.
This kind of self reinforcing cycle could play a huge role in obesity,
but it's important to stress that you can find this process and reverse it by
eating healthily and breeding mauled good bacteria.
Beyond weight gain.
Our biome has also been linked to other serious diseases like autism,
schizophrenia and cancer.
One of the earliest symptoms of Parkinson's is actually gut problems.
If your body is overrun with bacteria that harm you,
there is often only one solution.
You bring in an army of good guys.
That's very easy.
You just transplant some healthy poop.
You do that by literally transferring poop from a healthy person into your gut.
This method is already used to cure diarrhea.
That's caused when c difficile bacteria takeover a gut microbiome,
but we just don't know enough about the complex interplay at work here yet.
For example,
the transplant from an overweight donor cured a woman's diarrhea,
but contributed to her obesity down the line.
This cause some ways,
and another study tried to reverse the effects.
Poop transplants from slim people to obese ones,
gave them a more diverse microbiome and made them less sensitive to incident
both things.
That also happened when people lose weight.
We need to do a lot more science to really understand how our microbes make us
healthy or sick,
but whether we like it or not,
we need our micro biome and it needs us.
We'll never have our bodies to ourselves,
but we have gained a powerful ally if we can just keep the peace.